Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Abend. Mein Name ist Istane Koca Saraj. Ich bin heute die Dienstabende Erdstin hier und würde jetzt gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja. Ich muss jetzt erklären. Es ist ein Patient zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ich frage gleich den Namen. Das ist Herr Beiderbeck. Er ist aber gekommen in Begleitung der Ehefrau und des Sohnes.
Herr Beiderbeck, seit gestern nicht mehr richtig orientiert ist und sich nicht mehr genau ausdrücken kann.
Deshalb kommt die Frau mit und sie erheben jetzt mehr oder weniger eine Fremdanamnese.
Okay.
Okay. Wie heißt der Patient?
Mein Mann heißt Maximilian Beiderbeck.
Können Sie bitte Namen langsam buchen?
Maximilian M A X I M I L I A N. Maximilian.
Und Beiderbeck B E I D E R E C K. Beiderbeck.
Beiderbeck. Okay.
Wie alt ist Herr Beiderbeck?
Mein Mann ist 68 Jahre alt.
61.
Okay.
Wann ist er genau geboren?
Am 24. März 1963.
Okay. Wie groß ist er und wer ist er?
Ich glaube mein Mann ist 1 Meter 84 groß und 90 Kilo ungefähr.
Okay.
Ich möchte gerne Ihren Namen auf.
Frau Beiderbeck.
Mein Name ist Marianne Beiderbeck.
Okay.
Frau Beiderbeck. Was fühlt sie zu uns?
Also wie, was mich bei Ihnen hat?
Also ich habe, seit gestern beobachte ich, dass mein Mann sich sehr verändert hat.
Er ist teilweise sehr unruhig, teilweise aber auch sehr schläfrig.
Und er weiß nicht genau, welches Datum wir haben, welches Jahr.
Das bringt er alles durcheinander, seit gestern.
Und er geht auch sehr unsicher. Er schwankt so und ich habe immer die Befürchtung, dass er hinfällt.
Er muss sich dann oft festhalten und auf dem Weg zur Toilette in der letzten Nacht ist er gestürzt.
Aber er hat sich wohl nichts verletzt.
Seit gestern hat er diese Beschwerden.
Wie sind die Beschwerden aufgetreten plötzlich oder langsam?
Langsam.
Also, Herr Beiderbeck, an irgendeinem Fall chronische Erkrankungen zum Beispiel.
Ja, mein Mann hat hohen Blutdruck, ungefähr seit zehn Jahren.
Aber wir messen sehr regelmäßig den Blutdruck.
War mal der Messer?
Bestimmt fünf bis sieben Mal in der Woche messen wir den Blutdruck.
Und er war in letzter Zeit aber immer normal.
Er war immer unter 140 und unter 90.
Und das sind Werte, die hat uns unsere Hausärztin genannt.
Da soll der Blutdruck sein, da drunter und das ist er auch.
Okay, seit gestern aber haben Sie aufgemessen?
Ja, gestern habe ich auch mal gemessen.
Da war er, glaube ich, 130, 135 auf 85.
135? Okay.
Hat Herr Beiderbeck Fieber oder Schützefrost?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe jetzt nicht gemessen, aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Herr Beiderbeck fast hingefallen hat.
Ja, in der Nacht ist er einmal hingefallen auf dem Weg zur Toilette.
Er wollte Wasser lassen.
Okay. Hat er verletzt?
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass er sich verletzt hat.
Es hat nirgendwo geblutet.
Er konnte auch alles soweit wieder bewegen.
Aber wir haben einen starken Schritt bekommen.
Kann er mit Ihnen kontaktieren, also Burtschütze?
Ja, manche Dinge kann er mir schon sagen, aber eben es wechselt so stark.
Manchmal ist er ganz aufmerksam, aber dann wiederum ist er ziemlich
stäfrig und dann wieder sehr unruhig.
Das hat sich seit gestern sehr verändert.
Hat er weitere Bescheiden, zum Beispiel Kopfschmerzen?
Er hat etwas über Kopfschmerzen geklagt gestern.
In letzter Zeit, in den letzten Stunden, nicht mehr so.
Aber gestern, als das anfing, hatte er mehrfach gesagt,
er hätte so einen Kopf brummen.
Er nennt das Kopf Brummen.
Wissen Sie vielleicht, strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus
oder wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Das kann ich nicht sagen, wie stark die sind.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die Schmerzen ausstrahlen.
Hat er ihr Besuchsein verloren?
Nein, nein, glaube ich nicht.
Nicht in meiner Anwesenheit.
Leidet er schwindel?
Ja, es ist eben schwindelig.
Er sagt mir, es ist schwindelig und deswegen kann er nicht so sicher gehen.
Er muss sich immer abstützen.
Er sagt, er ist etwas übel, aber er hat bisher nicht erbrochen.
Hat er Sehstürmchen oder Hörminderungen bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Er trägt Höhrgeräte, er hat ja aber schon einige Jahre.
Das war bisher nicht auffällig.
Hat er, ist ihm aufgefallen, dass er Taubheitsgefühl oder muskelsche Weche in den Beinen oder in den Armen?
Darüber hat er nicht geklagt oder nicht berichtet.
Hat er ein Taubheitsgefühl oder so? Nein, hat er nicht.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt mit muskelsche Weche?
Sie haben schon erredet, das hat er gestürzt.
In der Nacht ist er einmal hingefallen, auf dem Weg zur Toilette, im Flur.
Er fährt immer ganz regelmäßig Fahrrad, er fährt jeden Tag mit dem Fahrrad.
Aber das könnte er jetzt gar nicht mit dem Rad fahren, das geht gar nicht.
Das ist nicht in der Lage.
Hat er gleichzeitig Herzrasen, Herzklopfen oder Atemnot erregt?
Mein Mann hat Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Das hat er seit fünf Jahren.
Vor vier Jahren wurde in der Klinik eine Katheter-Untersuchung gemacht.
Da wollten die Ärzte auch diese Herzrhythmusstörung behandeln.
Das hat aber nicht erfolgreich.
Er nimmt regelmäßig ein Medikament zur Blutverdünnung.
Er hat bei der Medikamate regelmäßig eingenommen.
Da abdeh ich drauf. Das wird immer regelmäßig eingenommen.
Wie ist sein Appetit?
Normalerweise ist der Appetit gut.
Aber seitdem er gestern so verändert ist, hat er kaum was gegessen.
Er hat immer gesagt, er muss was trinken.
Das hat er auch gemacht, aber gegessen hat er wenig.
Seit gestern ist das verändert.
Hat sein Gewicht in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Nein, es ist immer gleichgeblieben.
Wie sieht sein Schlafpoethet aus?
Normalerweise schläft er gut.
Er hat in der Nacht 2-mal auf Toilette Wasser gelassen.
Aber danach schläft er wieder gut ein.
Normalerweise war er in der letzten Nacht sehr unruhig.
Da hat er nicht gut geschlafen.
Ich habe auch nicht gut geschlafen.
Er hat auch abgesehen von den Nächsten Wasser gelassen.
Er hat mit Wasser gelassen oder mit Schülern beschwerden.
Nein.
Haben Sie bei Ihnen geschwüne Beine bemerkt?
Nein, hat er bisher auch nicht darüber berichtet.
Er hat nicht aufgefallen.
Er hat abgesehen von Blutvogdruck und Herzlitmuskiterung.
Leider hat er andere Krankheiten.
Nein, es sind diese beiden Krankheiten,
wo er auch Medikamente nehmen muss.
Er nimmt einmal, ich habe das auf dem Zettel,
und bei Blutdruck nimmt er bisoprolol 5.
2 Tabletten am Tag, 1 morgens und 1 abends.
Er nimmt noch Ramipril 5.
1 Tablette morgens und 1 Tablette abends.
Er nimmt noch ein Mittel,
damit das Blut etwas flüssiger ist.
Das heißt Lixiana, mit X.
Er steht 60, da nimmt er 1 Tablette.
Und?
Okay. Ist Herr Beiderbeck schon einmal offiziell zuordnen?
Ich meine, als Kind ist er operiert worden am Blinddamm und an den Mandeln.
Was hat er mir mal erzählt? Ah, Blinddamm und Mandeln, Blinddamm und Nabe hat er.
Okay. Ist Herr Beiderbeck hier allergien oder unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein. Er verträgt alles vom Essen, er kann alles essen, bis er hat ihm alles vertragen.
Ist er oder sind Sie irgendwo hingereist in den nächsten Seiten?
In welche Zeit meinen Sie?
Letzte, drei Monate, zum Beispiel.
Da waren wir nur einmal fünf Tage in Berlin, aber sonst waren wir im letzten Sommer zwei Wochen an der Ostsee, aber keine Fernreise, keine weiten Weichen.
Das war immer im Land. Sie waren nicht master.
Ist Ihr vorständig?
Impfen, ja. Also die Hausärztin schaut da immer drauf und ich glaube, das war bisher alles immer auf dem neuen Stand.
Er hat Covid-Impfungen bekommen, ich glaube vier.
Und dann kriegt er immer Grippe-Impfungen im Winter und so weiter.
Ist Herr Beiderbeck rauchbar?
Nein, hat noch nie geraucht.
Niemals, das ist gut. Nimmt er regelmäßig Alkohol zu Sie?
Also selten trinkt er mal, glaube ich, abends eine Flasche Bier, aber das ist sehr selten. Das ist vielleicht einmal in der Woche.
Okay.
Und ich nehme an, dass Herr Beiderbeck nichts mit anderen Drogens mit uns haben.
Nein, nein, hat doch nicht.
Okay.
Ist Herr Beiderbecks Familie noch am Leben?
Sie meinen mit Familie Eltern, die Eltern.
Ja, die Eltern leben noch. Der Vater ist 86 Jahre alt, der hat auch hohen Blutdruck, hat eine schwere Knieatrose am linken Knie, aber er will sich nicht operieren lassen oder so, das will er nicht.
Er geht am Rolator und ist damit ganz zufrieden.
Okay.
Und er ist 84 Jahre alt, die hatte vor 20 Jahren Brustkrebs, das wurde damals operiert und bestrahlt und das ist aber soweit unauffällig.
Und dann ist es noch in den Jahren noch einen Bandscheibenvorfall, an der unten an der Lindenwerbelsäule und das musste aber nicht operiert werden.
Das wurde behandelt mit Krankengymnastik und mit Medikamen.
Alles gut.
Hat Herr Beiderbeck die Schwester?
Ja, er hat einen Bruder. Der Bruder ist 59 Jahre alt, soweit ich weiß, geht es dem Bruder gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Unser Sohn hier, der mitgekommen ist, der ist 34 Jahre alt und zwei Töchter, die sind 29 und 27 Jahre alt und die sind gesund.
Okay, das freut mich.
Ist Herr Beiderbeck berufstätig?
Ja, er arbeitet noch als Hausmeister in einer Schule.
Noch zwei Jahre und dann geht er wohl in Ruhestadt.
Ja, das ist gut.
Hat er Stress bei der Arbeit oder zu Hause?
Auch die Arbeit ist immer etwas stressig, aber das macht ihm immer noch Spaß.
Und zu Hause denke ich, glaube ich, nicht, dass er viel Stress hat.
Okay.
Sie haben schon erwähnt Herr Beiderbeck regelmäßig Fahrradfahrt.
Er hat auch abgesehen von Fahrradfahrern, schreibt er regelmäßig andere Sport zu Alten?
Er macht etwas Gymnastik, so zwei bis drei Mal in der Woche, morgens macht er etwas Gymnastik, meint er, das wäre wichtig für die Kraft und für den Körper, für die Gelenkigkeit.
Ja, aber sonst nicht. Aber er fährt sonst viel mit dem Fahrrad.
Ja.
Vor drei Wochen ist er mit dem Fahrrad gestürzt.
Das erinnere ich mich jetzt und hatte da eine kleine Kopfplatzwunde.
Da haben wir aber ein Pflaster drauf gemacht und dann hörte das auf zu bluten.
Wir haben da Eis drauf gemacht wegen dem Mittel gegen die Blutgerinnung, aber das hat dann aufgehört zu bluten.
Und was war dann in Ordnung?
Aber damals hatte er keine Bebelsein, Verlust oder Ohrmächtigkeit?
Nein, er ist aber alleine gestürzt. Ich war da nicht bei ihm.
Aber er meinte, er könnte sich an alles erinnern, wie das passiert ist und so.
Er wollte einem Hund ausweichen und dabei ist er mit dem Vorderrad in einen weichen Sand gekommen und dann ist er gestürzt.
Okay.
Das ist Ova Stravid.
Alles gut, Frau Beiderbeck.
Meinerseits habe ich alle wichtige Informationen gesammelt.
Fällt Ihnen noch etwas ein oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, wir machen uns schon Sorgen, was das sein kann, weil er ist ja so verändert.
So kenne ich ihn ja gar nicht.
Und ich hoffe, dass das wieder besser wird, weil er möchte ja auch noch ein bisschen was von seiner Rente.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen, Frau Beiderbeck.
Aber es ist so eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Erstmal muss ich Herr Beiderbeck körperlich untersuchen und ein paar Laborwerte bestimmen.
Wir brauchen dann bisgebende Verfahren, zum Beispiel Schädentomographie.
Und danach können wir genau besprechen, was er hat.
Okay, gut.
Das können wir so machen.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt ja etwas Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Und die anderen Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die zugehört zugeschaut haben, können ja gerne noch Fragen stellen, wenn noch Fragen übrig sind.
Diese Simulation ist sehr wichtig und sehr gut.
Seit fünf Jahren haben wir nur einmal eine Fremd an einem Nese durchgeführt.
Diese Simulation ist zweiter Fremd an einem Nese.
Okay.
Ich denke, das macht auch mal Sinn, weil es gibt natürlich viele Menschen, die auch dement sind, desorientiert sind und die dann in Begleitung kommen in die Aufnahme.
Und dann ist man angewiesen auf die fremd an einem Nese.
Angaben natürlich.
Danke schön.
Vielen Dank.
Sie sind so.
Ja, haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen.
Ich denke, alle Fragen stehen.
Ich muss folgende Fragen.
Sie haben gesagt, vor drei Jahren eine Fremd geschützt.
Vor drei Wochen.
Aber hat er ähnliche Beschwerden vor fünf Jahren?
Nein.
Er hat eine kleine Beschwerden, die jetzt seit gestern sind, wie er so verändert ist in der Psyche, in seinem allgemeinen Zustand.
Das ist seit gestern.
Das war noch nie.
Vor drei Wochen ist er mit dem Fahrrad gestürzt und hatte diese kleine Kopfplatzwunde.
Ich war bei dem Sturz aber nicht dabei.
Ich kann Ihnen nicht sagen, ob er bewusstlos war oder nicht.
Er hat mir berichtet, ja, das war der Hund.
Der Hund kam quer in meinen Weg und ich musste ausweichen und dabei bin ich gestürzt.
Hat er Ihre Medikamente regelmäßig eingenommen?
Ja.
In Lixiana?
Ja, das hat er immer eingenommen, ganz regelmäßig.
Da achte ich drauf.
Und er kontrolliert Ihre Kardiologin?
Ja.
Er geht regelmäßig einmal im Jahr zum Kardiologen.
Und da wird er es kontrolliert nochmal, sein Herz.
Das war aber bisher immer das Herz, auch der Kardiologe, das Herz ist eigentlich kräftig.
Aber eben die Herzrhythmostürungen sind da.
Nur unsere Kollegen haben nicht gefragt, Muskelsuckern.
Ja, Muskelzucken, die hat gefragt Muskelschwäche.
Muskelschwäche, die hat gefragt aber Muskelverkennung.
Oder Taubweilsgefühl hat sie gefragt.
Oder Muskelschwäche hat sie gefragt, ja, kann er alles bewegen?
Ich glaube, ich hatte auch gefragt, Muskelzucken jetzt nicht.
Aber Muskelzucken hat er eigentlich nicht.
Aber er ist manchmal sehr unruhig jetzt gewesen und dann wieder schläft er ein im Sessel
und dann sagt er, wieder mir ist übel.
Aber er hat keinen Appetit natürlich.
Es ist alles sehr eigenartig.
Aber seit und Ort Orientierung nicht.
Er konnte mir heute Morgen nicht sagen, was für einen Wochentag wir haben.
Konnte er mir nicht sagen.
Und welches Datum.
Und was macht mir schon Sorgen?
Sonst konnte er das immer.
Er war sonst immer fit im Kopf.
Okay.
Seit Orientation gibt es.
Aber Ort Orientation ist normal.
Er weiß, wo er ist.
Er weiß auch, dass er hier im Kontenhaus ist.
Aber er wusste die Zeit nicht genau.
Und das Datum, ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Frau Beidelberg, ist er in der letzten Zeit erkältet?
In der letzten Zeit was?
Erkältet.
Ja.
Nein.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrochen?
Übelkeit hat er ja.
Über Übelkeit.
Aber er hat bisher nicht erbrochen.
Ständig.
Bist richtig?
Okay.
Können wir als Herzgeschichte anfangen?
Hallo Beras.
Ja, ich bin da.
Der Oberarzt kommt jetzt gerade um die Ecke.
Danke schön.
Bitte schön.
Vielen Dank.
Wir haben einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Der heißt Maximilian Beidelberg.
Er ist 61 Jahre alt.
1,84 kg.
90 kg schwer.
Seine Frau.
Frau Beidelberg.
Hat ihn.
Er hat ihn bei uns mitgebracht.
Wegen seit gestern.
Unruhe.
Und Schlafneigung.
Oder Sonne-Lenz.
Sie können sagen,
Herr Beidelberg kommt in Begleitung.
In Begleitung seiner Ehefrau.
Und des Sohnes.
Er kommt in Begleitung.
Und er kommt in Begleitung.
Das ist einfacher,
als wenn Sie sagen,
Sie hat ihn mitgebracht.
In Begleitung.
Herr Beidelberg,
ich stelle Sie in Begleitung.
In Begleitung der Ehefrau.
Und des Sohnes.
Wegen seit gestern.
Und.
Orientierung.
Die Beschwerden sind langsam aufgetreten.
Und gestern Abend hat er einmal gestürzt.
Aber nicht verletzt.
Als Begleitung.
Er hat einen Kopfschmerzen seit gestern.
Und schwindelig.
Schwindelfrei.
Kennen Sie den medizinischen Ausdruck für Kopfschmerzen?
Und für Schwindel?
Cefalgi.
Und vertigo.
Ja, oder Cefaléa.
Und mit Übelkeit?
Mit Übelkeit, Nausea.
Cefalgi.
Und es ist erwähnt,
dass der Patient für drei Wochen
beim Fahrrad fahren.
Insomni und Nikturi, zweimal in der Nacht.
An der Vorerkrankung leide er arterialen Lekiparthoni seit zehn Jahren, aber seine Frau erwähnt, dass der Brutdruck unter Kontrolle ist.
Gestern haben sie auch gemessen als 130 zu 5,50.
Als er dem hat er Herzsignustörung seit fünf Jahren.
Vor vier Jahren wurde er mit Katheter behandelt, aber nicht erfolgreich.
Deswegen nehmen er regelmäßig Lixiana 660 mg einmal täglich und gegen arterialen Lekiparthoni bis zu 5 mg zweimal täglich ein.
Es bestehen Herzrhythmusstörungen.
An amnestisch bestehen Herzrhythmusstörungen seit fünf Jahren.
Vor vier Jahren erfolgte wohl eine Katheter-Aplation.
Wahrscheinlich weiß eine Aplation ohne Erfolg.
Deswegen jetzt auch die Behandlung mit Lixiana 660 mg einmal pro Tag.
Bei den Patienten ist sie abhandelektromi bekannt.
Fragen nach Allergie wurde verneint.
Herr Weiderbeck ist nicht saucher, trinkt gelegen sich Alkohol, ein Flasche Bier,
behandelt uns drogen Konsum wurde verneint.
An der familiären Anamnese ist Väterli Herrseits, arterialen Lekiparthoni,
donated Lixiana 660 mg,
pennyاب Manh
Er hat eine gesunde Bruder.
Er ist bei der Weg ist verheiratet.
Habe drei Kinder, die sind gesund.
Er ist Hausmeister von der Russ.
Er arbeitet in einer Schule.
Und habe Stress bei der Arbeit.
Er ist ein
Er hat ein regelmäßig Sport.
Er hat 2-3 Mal Probe und Er hat ein regelmäßig Fahrrad.
Okay, sehr gut.
Bei mir ist viel hängen geblieben.
Ich habe noch eine Rückfrage.
Sie erwähnen ein Unfallereignis vor drei Wochen.
Herr Weidaberg war mit dem Fahrrad gestürzt.
Er hatte sich eine Kopfwunde zugezogen.
Diese Wunde wurde sie chirurgisch behandelt?
Was wurde mit der Wunde gemacht?
Er hatte keine Belüstung und mit einem Verband hat er allein ...
Also diese Kopfwunde wurde praktisch von der Familie von Herrn Beiderbeck selbst behandelt.
Er suchte deswegen keinen Arzt auf.
Noch mal wichtig, gab es Hinweise bei dem Sturz auf ein Schädel-Hirntrauma, auf eine Komo-Zio-Zerebrie oder so etwas?
Haben Sie darüber Informationen?
Leider habe ich nicht.
Vielleicht kann ich später fragen.
Ja, also die Frau Beiderbeck hat ja berichtet, dass ihr Mann wohl keine Erinnerungsstörung hat an den Unfall oder an die Zeit davor.
Es besteht wohl keine Amnesie.
Ja, sicher.
Beiderbeck konnte berichten, wie es zu dem Unfall kam.
Die Ursache konnte er berichten.
Also das ist zumindest nicht sehr auffällig gewesen in der Schilderung.
Frau Beiderbeck war bei dem Unfall nicht anwesend.
Das war ein alleinunfallreicher Mund.
Gut, was ist denn Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Aufgrund der ananasischen Angaben habe ich Verdacht auf Apoplexy.
Okay.
Also ich würde sagen, die beiden Verdachtdiagnosen verdacht auf Apoplex, apoplektischen Insult und verdacht auf zum Beispiel subdurales Hematom nach
wahrscheinlich Bagatelltrauma.
Es war wohl keine schwere Verletzung, aber der Patient ist ein Risikopatient, was das angeht.
Und von der zeitlichen Ablauf her kann das durchaus passen, dass die Symptomatik erst nach drei Wochen auftritt.
Das habe ich mehrfach erlebt in der Praxis.
Patienten hatten einen Sturzereignis vor Wochen, können sich nicht mehr daran erinnern.
Und dann plötzlich werden sie auffällig und die Ursache war ein subdurales Hematom.
Das geht ja oft dann ganz langsam, sehr schleichend, aber plötzlich werden die Leute auffällig, dass es den der Umgebung auffällt.
Entweder in der Firma, im Beruf oder der Familie fällt plötzlich auf.
Der ist eine Wesensveränderung oder er ist agitiert oder schläfrig oder er fällt immerhin.
Er hat eine Fallneigung zu einer Seite und das kann natürlich passieren.
Die Blutung war wohl nicht sehr stark, aber es war eine Sickerblutung, die irgendwann zu einem Herdruck geführt hat.
Passiert durchaus und deswegen ist eine Frage immer nach einem Unfallereignis so wichtig.
Ich habe ihnen da etwas eine Brücke gebaut.
Ich habe gesagt, mein Mann fährt ja viel Fahrrad und mir fällt jetzt ein vor drei Wochen, ist er gestürzt.
Sie sollten das Unfallereignis bei so etwas immer abfragen.
Es kann ja auch manchmal sein, dass die Leute sich nicht erinnern können.
Und trotzdem machen sie ja in der Diagnostik eine Bildgebung, ein Schädelctee
und spätestens dann würden sie ja auch sehen, was es wahrscheinlich kein Apoplex ist,
sondern eben doch wahrscheinlich ein sub-Duratesematoben, was man dann bei mir haben kann.
Gut, aber ich finde, Sie haben das sehr ruhig, systematisch gemacht.
Sie haben sich nicht aus dem Konzept bringen lassen durch meine Zwischenfragen und Einwürfe.
Ich finde, das haben Sie sehr gut und entspannt gemacht.
Und ich hoffe, Sie sind auch in der Prüfung so entspannt.
Ja, ich hoffe.
Sie überlegen noch, dass Sie wirklich die Begriffe wie Brustkrebs gleich sich entweder unterstreichen oder farblich markieren
und sagen, das muss ich übersetzen in Fachsprache.
Das heißt dann Mama-Carzinälen.
Das haben Sie bei der Knie-Atrose gut gemacht, die Gorn-Atrose genannt.
Das war alles gut.
So ein paar Kleinigkeiten eben, aber das ist die Sache der Übung des Trainings.
Gut.